this um what are some of the other
business models people are missing do
you think like you know
wines technically easy here's a product
sell the product tell them
why they need to buy the product you
know media is reasonably easy
i have an audience you want my audience
you give me money to get to my audience
what are some of the other business
models that people need to know about
that they're maybe missing
um i i think that let's take a step back
so i think it's a great question i think
it's the question listen
i remember i look back i got sucked into
being a little bit more romantic too
back in 07 8 9 i was like
what are all these people doing they
need a business and then i got caught up
in the fever myself
of like maybe forgetting about it or not
worrying about it as much or maybe i was
just so damn busy but
you know you know when i hear you say
that all that's happened has made a hell
of a lot of sense to me
yeah you know you know to me if you
don't know how to if you don't have
something to sell
now a lot you could sell yourself you
know and the few elite have been able to
do that and
whether they sell books or public
speaking those are all ways to to
monetize
um but you know it's kind of like
interesting like when i hit you up
the other day on twitter and said the
magazine thing you're doing is
interesting
i was i've been thinking about that
quite a bit i've been thinking about the
hacker news reddit just for
marketing like there's things to do
right um
i think a lot of people don't know how
to sell a product so
here's a couple things i think one i'm
always worried that a lot of people
default into selling
information products and they overprice
it right they want like a thousand
dollars for their ebook
when you and i are putting that
information out for free so i don't want
that
um a physical product is always
interesting right so
listen there's a lot of people who could
have sustained it
here's one it's not where i went but i
easily
could pay rent or elude a day job
by selling t-shirts of my favorite
quotes that i've said right
if you're big enough you know so there's
products that you can turn out of the
things you've done
the other thing you can do is for me
i applied it to the business meaning i
created vayner media
but i didn't make it about me i actually
built an actual business
an agency they're out there so you can
build an agency you can you know
um and the other thing that i think you
can do
is and i've been waiting to do this
chris and actually i see this being a a
win for you and your career as an
outsider watching it
i'm very into teaming up with a product
so i'm waiting for somebody to come
along and say let's take this
and say this is a new ketchup and it's
delicious can i give you
you know and i just think this is it and
i jump in and i own 50
of it and i use all my marketing ways to
build you know if there's a soda company
up in boston that teams up with you and
you get 10
of it so like 50 with vitamin water
william shatner with priceline all these
you know legendary moves like that
you're totally right
but those guys unlike us in my opinion
get endorsement deals and i'll take
those if somebody wants to come up if
somebody wants to come
and give me a point to do an energy
drink for the entrepreneurial nation i'm
the crusher guy
i could i could consider that but i'm
actually talking about
you taking a year and becoming in
essence the cmo
the marketing partner you know to me i
can apply like
we all spew all these ideas like my
long-term plan is to execute it
to building brands and so you can apply
it to that
i mean listen let me give you another
example there's a lot of people in the
space that i respect that have
gotten day jobs and i say my god if they
would have just went to a day camp
let's say a camp a summer camp and said
get you know
if they were actually business people
that's the conversation here and said
give me 15
of this day camp if i market this stuff
on facebook twitter tumblr
if i do content marketing if i do
outbrain
upworthy if i do all these things this
business will be worth more
that's something that's on the table for
a lot of people they want the risk right
right it's being a business person and
that's the truth i was thinking